hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the pleasure of introducing you today to
brittany talissa king
who is an independent journalist and
freelance writer host of american shade
with brittany king on youtube
she received a master's in journalism at
new york university
and a bachelor's in writing at indiana
university
brittany welcome to dark horse thank you
so much for having me
so i should probably tell our audience
you and i have
spoken before gotten along very well and
my sense is that we could just simply
have a conversation and not say any more
in terms of uh the ground rules or
expectations
but just so everybody knows where we are
um
i believe as i think you do that we have
serious
issues surrounding race in the country
that there's a lot at stake
and that we are in danger of uh coming
apart
in some way that will be disastrous for
all of us and that the best thing that
people like you and i can do
is to model courageous conversations
and i should tell you i i have a thick
skin i don't
love discovering that i've got something
wrong but i would much rather discover
it than have it go unsaid
so please be candid and courageous in
pointing out anything you think i need
to know
that i might be missing and i will do
the same in return
that sound good i have things yeah but
thick skin too so
this would be great terrific okay so
brittany um i i know that you
consider yourself to be on something of
a journey with respect to
your understanding of race relations in
the us
do you want to say something about where
that where you are in that journey and
where you started
um where i'm at on that journey is
is ongoing to be honest um i don't think
i'll ever stop because i'm always a
student so i'm always gonna continue to
be learning
but my journey started with
um being a leader of a black lives
matter in columbus indiana
which is the hometown of former vice
president mike pence
and my journey started kind of before
that with protesting for
black lives matter after 2013 when they
first had that hashtag on twitter with
trayvon martin
and i was doing diane's for eric gardner
and for him
and then in 2016 when alton sterling and
phelana castile
died 24 hours back to back i had
a very overwhelming sense of anger and
rage and i felt the best way to get that
out was to protest that's what i needed
to do
so i went down got 15 or 20
friends of mine and we protested from
columbus city hall
we were there for two hours and i looked
at
a few of my friends and i said i i'm
tired of protesting and i'm sick of the
fact that we can recycle these posters
over and over again year and year out
and
long story short we spontaneously
started a black lives matter of columbus
after thoroughly
going through their objectives and
seeing how it would make sense for
columbus indiana
and so that is where i guess my journey
began
on really diving in on what was going on
with
race relations in america
so i know i have a history
in protest as well and i know that it's
often very easy to see
that things are wrong did you have a
sense when you began
about what you wanted to take place what
change you were hoping to bring about
yeah so during this time this was the
first year
um donald trump was president this was
when
a lot of hate crimes was happening this
is when
charlottesville happened um and things
of that nature
different white supremacist groups were
popping up around our city
and for me i was like it's a matter of
time before it happens here
what i wanted to happen was okay guys
let's let's finally
just pop this bubble of delusion that
racism is not here
in our city all because we can smile at
each other and all because there's
you know a bunch of different colors of
people here
um that we have a lot of things to take
care of and
let's nip it at the you know button and
get down to what's going on here locally
and so what black ice matter
did was we created respectful
unsafe spaces for dialogue to happen
where we talked about national issues
going on and then we talked about local
issues
and we also had another objective where
we wanted
a bridging with police and with
community we want the police to see who
they were protecting and serving
and then also we wanted to be more
involved with the
ways of how the police hire police
officers
and then also that included us going to
the city council boards and the police
board meetings and things of that nature
to see what was happening on a
fundamental level so that was the three
objectives
for black lives matter columbus so
is it fair to say that
your activism at that point was
targeted at preventing bad things
from taking place and affecting black
people
rather than transforming the system
as we know it into something different
than it is
i would say yes it was more so the
former but i would also
say that it wasn't it was a black lives
matter
chapter but the majority of people there
and
in our organization were 90 white there
was 1800
black people in columbus there's 40 000
people there
so while there might have been 15 people
apart
blm there was you know 100 white people
so i wanted there to be and i know we
at that point when i look back now i i
see
we were more of an unorthodox
blm if you want to say because we wanted
white people to get on the in on the
conversations and talk and be
candid and i know that
that raise the eyebrows and some other
blms
not to say they told us like you can't
do this but
it made more sense when they would come
in our city and see what was going on
but
for me i knew that it made sense for
columbus i couldn't act like we were
baltimore or gary or chicago
um i had to see what was going on in our
landscape
and see how effective we could be
locally and not try to shoot for the
stars to change the entire
world or change the united states but
let's just change this town
and hopefully that can ripple effect out
very interesting i must say in some ways
there's sort of two directions i want to
go from here but one of them
is that i have a very
mixed reaction to blm
because on the one hand the idea of blm
resonates with me and has from the
beginning my family has a long-standing
understanding that there is a chronic
problem
for people of african descent in
in america and that that demands
a solution and so i also believe that
black lives are chronically
undervalued in the u.s and that that
is something that can change and must
change
so at the level of the the label
i'm on board but at the level of what i
discover as i try to get closer to blm
i'm frequently horrified by some of the
things that the
organization at least seems to be about
and it sounds like
your chapter is one where frankly
i would have been welcome and i might
have felt
at home is that fair you would you would
have had a seat right next to me
you wanted um i would say and i tell
people this
because and i guess we'll get to that
later but i did kind of publicly
in a way kind of announce
might i'm just seeing i guess you can
say myself away from the national blm
of 2021 but i will tell you
this i feel like there's been phases of
blm there's like
we were in the phase i believe from like
2013 to about 2017
of its most like organic state
like when it was about anti-police
brutality which i think any american
should be for because it benefits
everyone
and um and
then there was 2018 was a particular
time
i think that was like phase two of it of
me even looking at it when i was at the
last year of
leaving my blm i started looking at the
national blm and i was just kind of like
something's off but i i internally was
questioning i wasn't outwardly like
saying like let's
get in front of this because it wasn't
really peaking but just something was
kind of off this is when
robin d'angelo came out with her book
white fragility and this was when
a lot of other things were happening and
i saw that the
organization's objectives started to get
ambiguous
and kind of vague and then also the
white people
participating who just came in with good
intentions of just like we want to learn
we want to listen we want to help
and it seemed very organic it felt like
at least in our organization
in other organizations that i was
treated like a peer
at that point to 2018
i felt like in a sense that
people were were selling books and
lectures and seminars and things of that
nature
to say it's not being good intentions
not good enough
like you have to showcase how in a way
show off how anti-racist you can get
and it became a performa performative
ally ship at that point where people
were more so invested in blm
to um perform allie [ __ ] rather than to
do it
um to act like they weren't a part of
the problem
than fixing the actual problem that's
fascinating
so it sounds like sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt you but it sounds like
you had an organization built around
what seemed intuitively
meaningful and worth pursuing locally
and you it was
overwhelmed by a perspective on racism
and anti-racism that was being
sold by big names at a national scale
that uh transformed your organization
away from your what sounds like very
reasonable intentions and into a
movement in which
uh effectively whites were
uh forced to show off and to one-up each
other in order to remain in the good
graces of the
of the of the organization yeah i i
would i want to make a point though with
i'm not not to say that that happened
with every single
white person that they became this moral
monster or something like that no
um i i would say i was just seeing a
national level
with like just seeing protests and
things of that nature
and just like even on social media just
how i felt like it was a performance art
piece for people
to post an instagram photo of their arm
around a black person
and being like i'm like is that for you
or for
them but for my organization i i was
pretty tight-knit with
with stuff like i had people i had a
mission i said we invite all creeds our
races this is for
respectful unsafe space and i i mean i
had it a very clear thing
to where you had to sign it
and if you did not abide by this went
rogue
if on social media you were um
creating hostile environments within
your post or whatever
you're out so you had a code of honor of
sorts that people had
yeah people had to sign it and i kept it
on file and i gave them a thing like it
it was it was to keep everyone
accountable
um and this is the bar it's set and you
need to stay at this bar
because if you're not you're not you are
going to
um you're off the direction in the path
that we're for
but just to pick up on the phases so the
last phase
now uh with 2019 to now with black lives
matter i feel like with the blessing of
getting a lot of funds
and getting a lot of attention
that can actually be a disservice and i
think black lives matter
there are so many businesses after 2018
that poured into black lives matter
and then those people kind of gained
control of what was happening
that the three black women i don't feel
like had much of a voice anymore that
the money had the voice
and that i feel like blm became more of
a marketing brand
it was a way for businesses to buy in to
showcase how racially tolerant they are
like netflix putting blm up or whatever
i'm like i mean i for me i could see
through i'm like you don't
i don't think you really care i think
you're just trying to save your business
and like it's almost like i'm
not gonna get like biblical but
it's almost in the sense of you know
putting
blood on your door and like the ghost
coming by and
like i don't know what's going on i'll
understand it but this is this don't
come in
it was kind of like just a safety net
safety guard see blm we can't be racist
and i think that's the phase we're in
but the thing is it's not it's it's
people aren't really
outwardly talking about this but there's
been at least
10 to 15 other black lives matter
chapters that
started when i started and started in
2014
that have come out and i believe it was
the new york times piece i'm not sure
but
there's like 10 black lives matter
chapters who called out the national blm
and said
you guys have millions of dollars and
you're not helping any of the chapters
there's still people homeless there's
people
hungry there's we want funds poured into
schools for
for black children minority children and
you guys are hoarding the money
why are you hoarding it like where is it
where's the leadership
why aren't these steps happening that
you said what's gonna happen six years
ago
like people were calling them out and of
course that's not really shown
on social media it's the antithesis to
what i believe beyond was
wanting to be but now i don't recognize
this blm
like so i can't in good faith attach
myself to it anymore
into the national blm but i do support
grassroots they are also
very frustrated because they believe in
the original idea of blm
and it's almost like
they don't and i've had these
discussions with so many people who
are not for blm at all and i and i will
have these talks with them
and they're like you know what that's
awesome that these people are doing
great work but why don't they just
change their name
like if they are so like um disgusted
what's happening right now i'm like
you know when you've done something for
six years and it's
and you've done a lot and you poured all
of yourself in it
and then you know people on the tailing
come and try to make it something
that is not you're trying to fight for
the originality of
what it's for and maybe it is a losing
game
but for me all i can do is
my work could be separate but when i do
see people online
you know talking about blm they're all
marxist they're all socialists they're
all coming i'm like
really all of them like
a few people say it and then everyone
says
that's everybody um but then on the same
end
they wouldn't want to be generalized by
what they believe in either
um so i try to be
a bridge i guess because even though i
i might go to a blm protest as a
journalist
as someone like to report about what's
happening
but i haven't done like you know
blm work since the end of 2018 but i
do champion the grassroots that are
still
out there feeding people doing all the
things that they can do
that you'll never know about because
they're not in it for the clout
they don't care about the attention
they're doing it because they care about
black lives mate care about what's going
on in america
and they cannot stand it when they see
other blms and i believe was in
washington dc
where they're telling white people with
their hands up and say you're
if you don't you're a white premise and
and the funny thing is
most those people were white right so
i actually called that out on twitter i
said
if the national blm if you don't
denounce this behavior
you are tainting your organization and
the people who did this
majority of them were white so you guys
don't care about black lives
at all because when this comes out in
the articles
and they see a blm told white people to
put their hands up or the white
supremacists
no one's going to think i wonder if
they're white no they're going to assume
horse that they were black and they
actually majority
of them weren't yes this is a pattern
i have seen as well many times that
there is this
um large number of white people some of
them i'm sure think they're doing the
right thing maybe most of them
but um it's very destructive and you
know
the bill doesn't necessarily go to them
um
there are a couple points i wanted to
make just before they get lost here
your point about businesses putting up
um
black lives matter signs and things
my wife heather calls that a don't hurt
me wall
right um and we see them all over the
place in portland here and
really once you start seeing them that
way it changes
your understanding of what's going on
you know that power is being wielded
right and anyway it's a
it's it's very important not to take
those signs at their word some of them
may mean what they say and some of them
do not mean what they say
they're really about uh fear
and it's not healthy yeah it's not
um that's funny that your wife says that
i
i believe that's 100 true um and it is
like not to say that some people
when they put that up they don't mean it
or if they put a george floyd
picture up they don't mean it but i
remember when i was in bedside and this
was like
right after i would say the george floyd
um protests were going on
and i was going through brooklyn
and and i told my friends in my and most
i told my friends that were black um
that and showing them pictures of these
stamps that were on the ground
and it was saying it's okay to be black
like everywhere and i was just like
excuse me i was like
thank you for giving permission that
it's okay to be me like i was
so mad so then after that i just it
it like i didn't i would walk by on the
street like every day to go to this
place where i would run and then
i started looking at every business and
then it was like black lives welcome
black lives this george floyd this
people selling george floyd shirts i'm
like
but i thought capitalism was racist so
why are you using capitalism to sell
george floyd's shirts like i was just
like
what why why do people want to one sell
black death why are
people wearing these these things i
can't breathe
and just wearing them just casually out
with their dogs and just smiling
just the picture of that was just odd
and
yeah i'm like our
our skin our tragedies just become
trendy and
it's just it's like almost cool and it's
hard and this is something i'm working
on so i don't want to keep elaborating
on this
but just yeah i unfortunately when i see
that
i don't feel it's authentic i feel like
like you're just trying to
safeguard and and be like just don't
don't hurt us
um we're not we're not the problem and
that's unfortunate but that's where i am
well it's interesting there's a reversal
here on the standard narrative what it
sounds like
is you put together an organization
it had beliefs and objectives that were
reasonable relative
to what you were experiencing and what
you saw and then something
washed over you and it's hard for me not
to reach the conclusion that effectively
what you're
facing is colonization by
a large powerful entity right you had an
organic
organic local entity that suddenly got
swallowed up by a movement that had
beliefs many of which i would say are
clearly
not true and has motives that you're
describing as potentially
not pure not true to the
to this to the hashtag and so that that
does feel like
you got colonized and that those who say
well why don't you just change your name
the answer is well
you know one should think very carefully
before you tell somebody
to surrender the thing that they've
built or the place where they've lived
and just hand it over to the colonizer
right i mean that's part of the problem
exactly that's exactly if they would
they would say it just like that they
don't want to surrender
um the mission to what they see isn't
the mission
and like i said they do their best to
combat
it but the media is not on their side so
well i find myself in a weirdly parallel
position here because
i have been a proud liberal my whole
adult life i come from liberal stock
several generations back
and i have watched not only
the political party that is supposed to
represent me but
the uh the
mainstream of liberal thought go
what i would say is insane in in many
cases it represents views that
look more like the opposite of
liberalism than they look like
liberalism to me
and many conservatives tell me well then
you're really one of us and my sense is
no i mean even if even if i'm the only
person even if there's nobody standing
for traditional
liberal principles they're still right
and so
the point is i'm not i'm not
surrendering them i'm not handing them
over to anybody else i
appreciate that there are conservatives
who are now defending these
you know you've got conservatives
conserving liberal
principles that were consensus
principles until 20 minutes ago
right that's interesting but i i feel
the same way like well
no i'm not moving i'm i'm sticking with
this and
these other folks are wrong and um you
know
win or lose i'm not i'm not going to i'm
not going to surrender it
exactly and i feel like in ways
um like i'm independent and i'm i don't
affiliate with like being a republican
or democrat i haven't for like five
years
um but depending on what i say people
are like no you really are on a liberal
no you really are
you know concerned i'm like i'm just
here thinking and if it sounds that way
fine but
i'm telling you i'm not on a side
um but i think
what's going on especially when i do
talk about
you know cancel culture or with um
the anti-racist movement going on and i
speak out
against the movement not necessarily the
people but the movement
um you know i might be called you know
a conservative or whatever but
i'm calling out the fact that they
have turned something that's more
realistic
which is respecting each other
into some unrealistic goal where it's
not even about pro
about progression anymore for them it's
about perfection
like they want everything no racism ever
and any iota of it that means we're not
done we haven't nothing's
changed uh we're still you know
um there's still whatever racism's here
and the needle hasn't been moved
but you can't end racism and i think
that's
the goal on that extreme side is to end
racism and that is some
unrealistic tasks that you can't do it's
an emotion
people choose to be racist i mean with
laws and policies and legislation
that's where you can make a change with
racism
the uh so i don't know
if we disagree here or not but my sense
is that if i listen very carefully to
what i hear from
the the large mainstream blm
movement i can't even make sense
of the various claims if i try to
compare them to each other
you know the idea that we have to obsess
over
the bigotry of whites and then we're
also told
that it's incurable right these two
things don't fit naturally together
either it is curable
in which case obsessing about it is at
least arguably a reasonable thing to do
but
if it's curable then you have to ask the
question about
which whites are cured already and which
aren't and
it's like in order not to do that in
order just to say hey this is actually
really simple all whites are racist
you have to imagine that it's incurable
but then you've undermined the entire
rationale
for for doing what you're doing it's
it's really just
about uh retribution um so you mean in a
sense
just so we're clear like when they say
um
like white people can never not be
racist and like it's an endless work
that forever they'll have to be okay
yeah
exactly and i mean it personally i
believe
i believe this is actually not difficult
for
people to sort out in good faith and if
i can just
lay out my rubric you tell me if i've
got something wrong as you see it but
my feeling is that
racism and white supremacy require
at the very least one of two things they
either require
that you're actually rooting for your
race above others
rather than rooting for a level playing
field
or that your ignorance of
the challenges is willful
right so my sense is we all have
ignorance i am
forever going to be ignorant of what it
is like to be a woman
to be gay to be black to be an indian
i won't know these things firsthand but
i'm interested
i want to know as much as i can because
it makes me a better human being and it
makes me a better partner and so
i don't i don't want to be convicted of
being a bigot if my point is look i'm
actually
working to understand what i don't know
and i acknowledge that i will never know
it
as i would if it were me right so
my sense is okay broad brush that's a
fair position to shoot for
and it doesn't deserve a conviction for
white supremacy
uh or racism and so what does one do in
a world where we're told no
no you you have these things built in
there's nothing you can do and
your intent doesn't matter right it's
like well
didn't you just tell me i lose because i
lose i mean it's a tautology
malcolm x talked about and this is one
reason why i really like malcolm x
he talked about a lot with with the
black holes with black families and just
black people that
we can't wait around for white people to
change we can't wait around
for america to catch up to our freedom
we
have to just live free be free take
authority of our lives
and before you know someone else does
and
so he was for just go out there and be
american
anyways and
i think
it's it's hard to it's hard for me i
i don't believe that racism
is something that is
on an interpersonal level like terminal
i think this country yes was founded on
american slavery
and racism will always be within the
fabric of america
inevitably unfortunately it just will
so we either realize that
and try to
have different conversations about race
to try to unbind ourselves and untether
us
away from it as much as we can
or we keep being in within a fight that
we are basically telling
to the world we're going to lose because
if you're always trying to
get white people to not be racist but
they will always be racist you're
fighting a losing battle
so if that makes sense i go on tangents
first no no no no no
this is important and i i think it's
exactly where we should be
um i will tell you i'm less fatalistic
about the idea
that there will always be racism
in the u.s i mean you know at one level
we can measure with such precision you
know it's a big country will there
always be somebody somewhere
you know who espouses obnoxious beliefs
of course
but will it be a meaningful feature of
the landscape
i really don't believe that that has to
be the case and in part i think maybe
the difference in your perspective and
mind might come down to our age
how old are you i'm 31 31.
so i'm 52 and i've seen so much
change in this even you know 52 isn't
that old
right it doesn't take me back into the
60s
right this is more recent than that and
yet i still saw a tremendous amount of
progress
and i also you know i mean there's a lot
i don't know if we can even really do
this well in a conversation
it's it's it's very fraught at the
moment but
my own personal interactions with people
cross-racial not just
black people but across many different
racial divides
gives me an ability to see how this has
changed over time and part of that is
my own growth as a person but part of
that is also just a measure of
where we are and i i think the thing
that's really
is hopeful about the sort of longer term
trajectory and very frightening about
the
last few years is that i know that we
are making
rapid negative progress at the moment we
are moving
in the wrong direction and relationships
that were moving in the direction of
better comprehension of each other
and more compassion are now definitely
disintegrating and you know i used to
i've never been
um uncomfortable
interacting with people of other
backgrounds
and i noticed that i i was in a part of
town
and i was walking i don't know back to
my car or something
and i was passing through a park where
there was a
large black family i mean it was clearly
a familial gathering
probably 15 15 20 people
kids playing and all they were having a
barbecue in the park
and i know that five years ago i
wouldn't have thought twice
about walking through this park and
that it was almost certain that i would
have a nice exchange of words
with somebody about the beauty of the
day or
nice day for a picnic or whatever
whatever might have been said and i
can't speak for what's on the other side
of that interaction
but i know that every time i reach
across
some line and i get back a
a sense of camaraderie from the other
side it feels good it feels like a
little
bit of building of a project that i know
we're all
working on and i know or at least we
should all be working on and that it's a
long-term
thing right and instead
when i saw this it's like well i don't
even know where i am anymore
because i don't know what the
assumptions
of you know a white person
walking through a park and you know
interacting with somebody's family
barbecue i don't know if this is the
interaction i would expect from the past
or it's a new interaction in which the
assumption is that race is the
you know is definitely the subject of
the interaction
right and it's i mean it's both
terrifying and sad
that's interesting because
so i i i want to say like is it your
hesitation
because of the racial climate now or
certain instances like um
the woman who called the police on
no i think that was a pretty
extraordinary event in
in a number of different ways so i just
take it as an unusual
anomaly but i guess what i
there's a phenomenon where under normal
circumstances what i'm calling normal
circumstances and who knows what i'm
missing
right who knows what i don't know about
the interactions on the other side
of these interchanges that i've had for
my whole life right but
my assumption is i read people pretty
well
and that i know when somebody is
uncomfortable and when somebody feels at
ease
and there's something that strangers do
within race between race
within sex between sex and it is just
like a little
uh you know in computer science terms it
would be ping
ack right it's like you send a message
it says hey i'm here i see you and the
other person sends a message back says
see you right back right and the point
is
that could be like tense interaction
right you can imagine having an
interaction
in some part of town where you didn't
feel comfortable or in some department
of your work where you weren't welcome
or who knows
and you know that ping act would be
tense
but in general in public people actually
kind of like
camaraderie that's built of unspoken
stuff you know we live in the same town
we're enjoying the same day
right we're you know delighted to see
the kids playing in the park on
the equipment whatever it is there's
just something nice about um
feeling at ease and comfortable with
whom you're around and so the problem is
that i've now seen
so many interactions where
if there is an interracial dynamic then
race
is the subject and race is the subject
from a perspective of that we have an
urgent problem that must be addressed
here and now because the problem is
definitely here in this park
right and my sense is i don't know if
it's here in this park maybe it is but
maybe it isn't and if we don't leave
open the possibility that it isn't in
this park
then we're in big trouble
yeah i so i'm smiling because what
you're describing is the sense of like
this
paranoia right that is something black
americans have gone through before all
of this
i will say i know what you're feeling
is what we feel what i felt at when i
really understood that i wasn't white
at like 9 10 when i really understood
before then i would go in anywhere like
yeah you know but then when i
had that these encounters where i'm like
i know i'm not white but dang i didn't
realize there was some difference okay
now i move different in the world
and then since then that's how i feel
when i would
be the only black person going into a
white space
what do they think of me did they say
this thing about me because i'm black
and it could be not that at all but the
paranoia lingers there
and and the same as
am i being followed around you know
in this store because i'm young or is it
because i'm black am i not being served
because
this or because i'm black or
and and people now want to shut down
those
those narratives or those notions and
just say it's not about your race like
quit talking about your race if you stop
talking about it
it won't be an issue and they don't get
the paranoia you don't like that
you don't want that you wish it wasn't
there
i don't want to go into a store and feel
like my race is the one thing people see
i hate
like it's annoying and now i make sure
that if something happens i make sure
i actually think about it before i react
for me mostly um but before
what you're feeling in that park is what
black americans feel
all the time and we're not exaggerating
where if someone's like oh you're very
articulate
yeah that i am going to think you and i
won't the whole script paragraph you
think i'm articulate because you think
black people are stupid therefore you're
shocked that i can say a sentence
like that it's just very and
it's annoying and
the thing is is like sometimes
you know you or someone else that might
feel like
oh i want to interact with this black
family or whoever
it might feel like a tension of don't
come over here
it might actually be more of us feeling
like
we're not a danger to you so
it's a mixed signal thing everyone's on
edge
but if someone could really
rewind and listen to what you said
that is exactly what it feels like when
you feel people have a problem with your
skin and they don't know you and you're
like
is it because of that though and just
that paranoia is like a bug you're just
so
annoyed all the time you're like when
will this stop
and yeah exactly well i
totally agree with this not lost on me
um
but i would say a something i've said
many many times is that the problem with
this woke revolution is that it
is not interested in ending oppression
it is interested in turning the tables
of oppression
and so in some sense i feel that this is
and it's not irrational right i actually
do think
that people who do have racism
by the definition that i spelled it out
somebody who is actually rooting for one
race over another
that such a person needs to experience
this in order to just develop compassion
right that it is an important experience
but
my sense is that the interactions i've
been having for my whole life
when and let's take it out of the racial
dynamic here for a second just so that
we can see what we're talking about
i have also watched the same positive
thing
collapse between men and women right so
it used to be
that if i was walking down the street
and there was a woman walking the other
way
there's a way to exchange a look or
a greeting or something that defuses any
fear that i'm a creep that i'm a danger
to her that i'm on the make whatever it
may be
right that has become almost impossible
there is this way in which women walk
down a street
and it's just short of an accusation i
don't feel the accusation but i feel
like
you know i'm attempting not to make eye
contact because
there's only bad stuff that happens when
i do and so there's no ability to signal
i'm not a threat to you and i know that
there are threats to you out here but
that's not me
right and this so i i think the point is
a little bit of positive work was done
in the past
when let's take the um
the experience that you report that
paranoia of not knowing what white
people are thinking of you
because of your skin color right do you
have the experience that sometimes
you meet a white person that you don't
know in some circumstance
and that paranoia is diffused by the way
they interact with you
um that they have a problem with me
being black
no no i'm wondering if let's say you
enter an interaction
with some white person that you don't
know and
maybe the paranoia is there because you
don't know what they're going to think
right
but then in a few minutes of interacting
you realize oh yeah this isn't
this isn't a problem person this is
somebody who's you know
they don't understand what it's like to
be you but they're on board with the
idea
that race shouldn't matter in you know
except in the rare case where
it has to matter for some reason right
like it matters if you're talking to a
doctor about skin cancer or something
yeah that's happened before um
that's definitely happened i don't know
when this was
i think this was in brooklyn
i know that i was being waited on for a
little longer
and my waitress
was white and she like made it very
apparent of why
it was taking a while like yp like not
even like
i know you weren't served but just like
i'm so sorry we were backed up like
being really
apologetic and i don't know if she just
saw like maybe i had an annoyance on my
face and
or if she felt like oh she thinks she's
not being circus she's black i don't
know what she thought but she made it a
point
to make sure that i knew like it's not
for any other reason that we are
backed in staff and then that was when i
was like okay
but i mean those those happen i can't
really like
it's not really pinged in my mind but
throughout my life
that's happened a lot just with
maybe going into certain
um especially with black lives matter
okay
especially when i would be going into
meetings where i was like hi if
city officials were there and i'm in the
room and we're talking
um and i'm assuming people
are want to grill me or when it whatever
and then just the conversation's just
different than i thought and it becomes
one of
few great conversations i've had it's
just yeah things like that happen
a lot um throughout my life
um and while that might happen a
negative experience happens
so that is why that paranoia stays
and sticks because you just don't know
and i hope to always be pleasantly
surprised
but it's not to say that i don't on my
end i don't make sure that
they know i'm open to
this exchange too i don't wait for them
to think they have to do the work
yeah that makes sense like i i also
engage where it's like i know there's an
elephant
in the room which is our skin that's not
happening with me yep so yeah
well so i i want
a world in which effectively
it is you know everybody is aware of the
same thing right
i don't know if this is exactly fair you
can help me correct it if it's not
but my sense is that
there's a gray area but that by and
large a black
person knows when they're dealing with
somebody who's got an issue
they may not know exactly what the issue
is but you can detect it
right there's something hidden you know
i deal with this a little bit being
jewish they're people who
have some kind of suspicion about what
that is it's pretty rare that i
encounter it but i do encounter it
and then there are people who have some
very superficial
you know they'll like recognize that my
name is jewish or that i
look jewish and you know
i have the sense that you know it is
noted and then
in interacting it doesn't typically end
up being an important fact and it
dissipates
but my sense is that you probably in
general know
whether or not somebody has an issue
that's unstated
or whether somebody really doesn't have
an issue and then there's probably some
gray area where you don't know for sure
is that fair definitely okay and when
there is gray
i like you say might take notes but i
don't create it into something i kind of
just let
it be perfect so imagine that the
well-intentioned white folk knew
that this was kind of the rubric right
that when you meet black people
if you've got a real issue they'll know
it if you don't have a real issue
they'll figure it out and if you're a
little bit uncomfortable that might get
noted but it's not
you know it still leaves room to
discover that you're cool and that you
have
you know cool stuff to interact about
you have shared interests or whatever
if people knew that and the point was
okay
most of us in fact i will tell you i
think the thing that that i know
that you can't know is what gets said
when you're not in the room
right so i know what those conversations
about i don't want to know
you do no i do in general you do because
in general
it's not what you fear right that i i
never hear that conversation or almost
never right
um you know so anyway i'm in a position
that to help you calibrate
because i mean this whole you know you
mentioned the question of uh
using the word articulate with a black
person
this is now a problem for white people
like me who use the word articulate
because it's something i value and i
would use it for anybody who is
articulate and now there's this
very difficult calculation which is okay
i'm pretty sure there's something wrong
with the fact that i think being
articulate is good
and if somebody is black and articulate
i can't use that word
right that's a problem right but i get
why it's i get why this is an issue i
get that it is used by whites and it
has this coded level to it but it
doesn't mean that everybody who uses it
uses it that way and yet
even though i don't think i have a
problem with this i now don't know what
to do with that word
right it is allowed for certain people
and not others
yes it's sad that that's a word that's
taboo
but there's a lot of historical context
with that i i will say
just examples of that with my american
shade podcast
um a lot of people come on and
and i get these comments all the time um
let's just say i might have a bandana on
in one of my
videos and that's all they see in the
thumbnail and
then they click and they hear me talk
and then the comment is like
i'm going to be honest with myself and
publicly announce this i thought you
were going to be
the typical woke like thug um
yo yo yo like i'm not kidding like they
will say this
but they're like but you're a very
intelligent articulate
young wise woman and blah blah blah
thinking that i'm going to like the
comment like it's
i i understand that they're trying to be
open
so i don't delete these things though
i'm not like dilly no i let them be
because i'm like those are the moments
where like i
just really like try to pull in my
christianity as much as i can
i'm like you know what they're human
being vulnerable
and there's even though this is very
ignorant
my channel is about these conversations
and they are
telling me explicitly what they thought
of me
and now they don't so at the end of the
day is this something
it is bad right but it's
something that changed their perception
so maybe
next time when they see a group of kids
with bandanas
maybe they won't have the initial
reaction that these are thugs
maybe maybe that will help but i get
these all the time and then when you
hear
um you know especially with obama yes he
was articulate
but when you just hear like this
president was this this this and they
just
are you know but then when it was with
obama who were like
wow like he can speak clear
yeah that's gonna be annoying we're
gonna be like well why is
this one president the articulate one
i mean weren't they all or is it
expected for the rest of them to be
and this one wasn't well if i can if i
can just say for my part
i should say i have mixed emotions about
obama i voted for him once i didn't vote
for him twice
and uh the problem is i actually really
interpersonally i like him i think he's
a very likable guy and i did find him
extraordinary as a speaker like he stood
out right
he was really really good um it was at a
policy level and i still don't know why
he i thought he was a mess at a policy
level and you know it's possible that he
couldn't do better but there were some
things i just can't explain that way but
never mind that i think i think the
problem is that in his case
um he he'd be unusual
in any configuration he was a
i don't know what exactly explains him
unusual
developmental history uh that
you know a very singular human
and um so anyway the problem is that in
describing
such a singular human who happens to be
singular
as a president in this particular way
also right
our first black president um these
things get tangled up
because you're no matter what you're
doing you're describing
you know a one in seven
billion phenomenon right no matter what
yeah and so anyway i don't know what to
do with it exactly but the problem is
at some level let's just both agree
you and i have both encountered a
problem with the word
uh articulate the problem with the word
articulate that we have is inverse you
don't know what people are really
implying when they say it and i don't
know how to use it anymore because i
know that that's a
hazard that it's like a word that now
has all of this
potential energy built up in it and even
if
i'm perfectly even-handed in how i use
it and basically i just use it anytime
somebody speaks in a way that impresses
me
there's no way any individual could know
that right so
can't know if it's charged right
so what we need at some level i'm
certain
is enough interaction
that we're not dealing from these
anecdotes
and the problem for me
i tweeted about this earlier this week i
tweeted
segregation causes racism
and i don't mean that the opposite isn't
also true because i believe the opposite
is clearly true
um but i think the problem is
much of the what passes for
sophistication
in these social justice circles is the
idea that what we need to do
is group by skin color right
and while i know that there is
the need to be able to do that sometimes
right that
you know it makes perfect sense that if
a group of people is facing
a phenomenon they might need to talk
about it amongst themselves right so
the right to gather in such groups is
is important and it's a fundamental
right
but the need to always gather in those
groups is causing us to know less and
less about each other
and i i i feel like that's
utterly counterproductive that it is
going to create racism where actually
racism was getting better
i now feel like in the last couple of
years it's getting worse and part of the
problem is
that it is getting harder to have a
casual interaction that might actually
allow you
to understand more
yes i agree with that and i think
just the shorter answer is there's just
a big trust issue
it's just a big trust issue and it's not
with every single
american or black american but
like you said when you're walking that
park you don't know if that person has
that trust issue
with you or not and it's better maybe
it's just better i walk around them
and don't interact um which then creates
more of a trust issue
exactly because if you don't just do it
you'll never know but
um then there are organizations that
really
have a trust issue with with white
people coming in because they don't know
if they have good intentions
they don't know if they can trust them
they they don't know if they're actually
another organization trying to
infiltrate them or trying to like
you know co-opt or whatever they they
don't know so they're like well it's
better that we just keep it
all black because at least we know
that everyone in here is for this cause
and better safe than sorry i think
people rather just be better safe than
sorry now
um for me
there are definitely times where you
have to be it's better to be safe than
sorry
but with conversations now i will have
conversations with anyone
and i'll be cautious but i rather be
like dang
that didn't go the way i wanted it to go
like i'd rather that
than never talking to someone that
i might feel might not be receptive to
me or whatever but
yeah i think at the end of the day it's
a trust issue um and i don't know
how that is tackled other than people
just coming out of their comfort zones
and yeah so let me ask you about
something i agree that coming out of our
stretching with respect to our comfort
zones is the thing that allows us
to discover our shared humanity and get
past the you know
bigotry if it's there or ignorance which
is definitely
there you know but reducing ignorance
would be a great goal
it's never going to be zero but the
thing that allows us to do that is
contact
and all of these tensions and suspicions
make contact more fraught more likely to
go awry
and less capable of doing what it needs
to do
so i just wanted to add one other thing
to that i've
i spend a lot of time listening to
conversations and i deliberately
listen when i can to conversations that
are primarily or exclusively black if
i'm
allowed to participate and i'm noticing
actually it is true of those
conversations but it's actually more
generally true of the social justice
landscape not just with respect to race
but there is a pattern in which
amongst people who are gathered
around an injustice there's a tendency
to be unable to reject any claim
that is consistent with that overall
concern
right so there's almost no uh assertion
you can make that's too absurd to be
thrown out you won't get a bunch of
people who are concerned about
uh racial injustice who will say well
actually that thing you're talking about
is
is innocent but the problem is real but
that particular example
isn't right it's like anything is an
example of the thing in question
you've seen this yes um
[Music]
i think a very
popular example of this is white silence
is violence
or um well actually
well actually yeah so that was actually
something that came up that i was like
this is
a contradiction that when it comes to
the protest
and when it comes to showing up for
black people
or or non-white people
at these demonstrations it's like white
silence is violence it's like if you
aren't there
you are racist or you're part of the
problem but when it comes to having
conversations in dialogue like this or
talking about um the injustices and
what's going on
that we want white people to be silent
you can't talk like you it's it's our
call
it's our voice you support what we say
and that was some and
definitely a narrative that was really
after white fragility
actually not i'm not gonna blame
everything on that book this was before
that but white for julie really pushed
it
for white people just to listen and
black people write about race because we
don't go through racism and
even though my organization with blm was
not participating in that
i definitely retweeted that though i
definitely
shared that sentiment online definitely
um because i thought that was agency
like i thought that was like
you know but then i realized does that
even make
sense that white people can't speak
because
racism yes happens
to black people but there are certain
parts of racism that we
will never experience from different
angles
and if we allow white people to speak
and give their
point of view what's going on they can
let us know of the blind spots we're not
seeing
and what's going on everyone has to
participate
in this issue like if we're saying it's
not just our issue
it's not just this go educate yourself
the best education is dialogue
it's not reading a book it's talking to
me
about it and but i think why we don't
want that is because it's like already
the stress of the incident and the
injustice
and then the additional stress of having
to talk about it
and make sense to it to other people
who don't just get it on ground level
but it's like
when has racism or race or the
conversation
promised to ever be comfortable it's
always going to be ugly and hard and
exhausting and that's what
has sobered me up to this because i was
always like i'm not talking to white
people about racism go google it
i'm not exhausting myself like i'm like
at the event i talk
at the meetings i talked after that but
now i'm like
when i look back at my lineage what
happened i'm like
dr king and them fought for our civil
rights and our
voting rights and other rights like
and then my ancestors you know
everything that they were able to do
fighting for me to be in this moment in
2021 and i can't have a conversation
with a white person
because it's exhausting but
like tell that to harriet tubman i'm
like here you tell me would be like if
you don't go
and like when i think of when you
contrast it with that
now for me i definitely
i'm human so i definitely have
conversations with people
that definitely go somewhere and it
might be a four-hour conversation at the
end of it
it might have so many things might have
happened that were great and i might go
to bed crying because it was so hard to
do
and it is exhausting but i'm like but
what they did for us this is a luxury
the fact that i can tell a white person
how i feel
and they'll listen and then change could
happen
like now i'm like now for me
i just i i exhaust myself because
what happens afterwards is always good
even if and there's been tension of
course
i consent to being offended they can
sense
to getting offended we we're like we're
mature we're like this might happen it
might get ugly
maybe it will probably actually will
and it always though
it just is surprising to me of
how i felt almost
like all the things that they did with
the struggle that was happening and
they pushed us along each era pushed
the the other era like okay we're free
we're free out of bondage and we're
pushing you forward
to whatever the freedom is and then
after reconstruction era pushing you
after jim crow now we're pushing this
generation
and we just and i want to say we i'll
just speak for me and then i was willing
to just to sit down
and fold my arms and be like i'm not
talking to anyone
when i looked at it that way i'm like oh
ways i'm lazy
like talking is the least i could do
if anything else um
but i don't want to put that on other
on all black people we have different
experiences and for me
because i grew up in a white town
i i do have a tolerance i
i because i'm used to being around white
people there's people in chicago and
other inner cities that
they've experienced um
encounters with white people way
different and i'm not going to tell them
like you need to do what i do
no i'm just going to do what i can do
which is this well i would say yeah it's
not incumbent on
any individual but it is vital for all
of us to the channel remain
open right that there be the ability to
have those conversations
yeah yeah and i i like your point quite
a bit
about um this instinct
to silence white people especially as
we are told that their silence is
violence but even
putting that aside the silencing of
white people in a conversation about
rock race is just
simply destructive of the ability of
that conversation
to reach insight because
the point is we're actually talking
about a dynamic and
as much as um i
don't know what it's like to be black
and can't therefore speak
from personal experience uh to to that
um
that phenomenon it is also true that
you know you can't know what goes on as
we said before in the room when you're
not there
and interesting to me that your first
reaction when i talked about what was
said in the room when you're not
there was that there was something to
fear about that
and can you tell me what you
feared might be said in rooms when when
you're not in there or when you walk out
wow i would say
honestly the the little things that just
came to mind that might be said
if i walked out of a room
maybe like i can't stand these people or
just just i actually i don't even like
i can't stand these people or you know
why they always trying to take up space
or
here we go with another blm like just
the stereotypical things one might think
someone's thinking in their mind when
they see them anyway
wow you know i it sounds like that's not
what happens never
never i mean i do sometimes hear people
say stuff that i think
might have racial content in it but it's
usually not
that a person is saying something that
is negative it's that a person
is doesn't know what to do with race and
so they're sort of revealing
their ignorance about it or something
like that but no no
no no i you know and and it's funny
because
i talked to other white people about
this phenomenon like
you know i was in fact having a
conversation with a journalist
uh jeremy lee quinn
and we were talking about he he's a
left-wing he's actually an anarchist
who's done journalism looking at
right-wing protests including the one at
the capitol
and um he encountered
a guy who was overtly
racist and he and i had this little
moment it was like oh
you actually met an overt racist in the
wild and it was like
yeah i did and it's like well that's
interesting because you and i
he and i are constantly being told that
it's everywhere
and we never meet these people right
that's not how it works and i'm not
saying
that there is not severe bias in our
system
but it's not written into the system
where you would expect it to be
right it's much more like your zip code
is not racially diverse and predicts
how well you will do in life right
that's a very
backward thing but it doesn't it's not
working through the active racism of
white people it's working through a
historical
fact which did come from racism right
the segregation of our neighborhoods
and it has tremendous impact it does
lots of harm
but it isn't working through what's said
in the room
when the black person leaves or when
there are no black people present it's a
totally different thing
and so this is part of this is part of
the problem i think is that
the the picture
of racism that is being portrayed is so
at odds with what's actually going on
and so much of people's acceptance that
it is right
is based in their fear rather than their
personal
encounters with it that we're just stuck
in this
i think fake story and frankly it's fake
on both sides the story about
white racism is a caricature of what
that actually is
and really i think we're dealing more
with historical racism that we are being
um we are failing to address rather than
current racism
it's not to say there's none but it's to
say there's a lot less than people say
um but you know on the other side too
the the understanding on the right
is uh cartoonish because the right
is unimaginative about the ways that
harm can afflict a population that
doesn't require active racism they just
think it's all made up
or not all of it but a lot of it and so
the point is look
actually both these stories have to go
we do have a problem
and it is not primarily active racism by
living
white people it works differently than
that but
you know so let's figure out what the
problem actually is
right and not demonize people who aren't
guilty of something
and then in so doing we could actually
address it which i think is essential
i don't think the country is complete
until we really do
address it um but you know that that
story
gets lost i mean it's a little like your
blm chapter
that got overwhelmed by
some bigger blm phenomenon that didn't
speak for you
right that view that like yes we have
real problems but it's not based in the
active racism
of white people or at least not
primarily so
it's just there's no oxygen for that
discussion because we're so busy having
a different discussion
i think what i was saying we lost
contact here for a moment
due to a zoom hiccup i think what i was
saying
was that we've got two false stories
that are taking up all the oxygen in the
room
one of them is that on the right there
is a belief that inequality
and race-based inequality is much less
significant than it actually is
and i i'm by this i mean equality of
opportunity
and on the left there's a story that the
reason that things are so unequal
is about active racism on the part of
whites that is
interfering with the ability of blacks
and others
to succeed and what i was suggesting is
that
um i'm virtually certain there's
obviously some degree of bias based on
the fact
that i am likely to encounter uh white
folks who are more similar minded to me
than different but i do a lot of
i intermingle with people across the
political spectrum i've done a lot of
traveling and it is
exceedingly rare that i run into anybody
who is actively rooting for white people
over black people
it is not exceedingly rare that i run
into people
who have very little understanding
of people of other races there's a lot
of ignorance
but i think very little of it is willful
and so the point is what i really want
to see is a discussion in which we say
okay
why are things so unequal and what can
we do about it
because frankly from all of our
perspective equality of opportunity is a
great thing
but we can't get to that discussion if
folks on the right are increasingly
emboldened
in believing that there isn't a problem
because folks on the left
are painting the problem differently and
more personally than it actually er
than it is actually occurring mm-hmm
i i want to play devil's advocate on
what you said
please um do you think that
you might not encounter overt racist
because it's not socially acceptable
and it's almost like
you know someone that is very uh
let's say misogynist or or whatever
they might not say that overtly to
someone
or showcase that overtly to someone
unless like
they have a commonality with that person
a friend or close to someone where they
can
be like that well you know that's a
possibility but
i i would i would say
i'm a very careful student of human
behavior i mean it's
professionally one of my primary
interests and it's also
something i i delight in you know i've
done a lot of traveling i spend a lot of
time talking to people and listening to
people
for a lot of different reasons partly
i hold the view that the
if somebody will let you look through
their eyes that that is like
an incredible privilege and that you
should
take that opportunity for the amazing
thing that it is and not treat it
frivolously
so you know i do sort of discover
people's myopia people's creativity
because i'm sort of curious about what
it's like in their heads
and i did this professionally also as a
professor for
14 years the college i was teaching at
students and professors took one class
at a time so professors taught one class
students
took one class and it could go on all
year so i knew
my students really really well and they
knew me
and so all i would say is that i can't
be certain of what i don't see because
people won't say it around me
but i know that i'm not depending
entirely on what they say
that i'm actually looking for patterns
and that
i frequently find ignorance i rarely
find what i would call racism
and that i think um yeah there's bound
to be some bias
in what people will say to me and some
bias in who i'm talking about
but i don't think that's what explains
it i think most people
across the political spectrum actually
really do believe
that an equal world racially speaking
is better and what we differ on is how
equal things are
um yeah i i just wanted i just wanted to
be
say do that devil's advocate but i will
say like
after i leave
this that paranoia isn't after any
exchange with any white person
it's it's certain times where you're
going into an unknown
territory and you're just unsure what
people say and you don't know if they're
being pleasant to your face and when you
walk out you have no idea what they're
really saying
but it's nothing that i go to bed
thinking of and rocking back and forth
and like i wonder what
no i i don't think that can i ask a
question
um and i don't i
don't i well this might not be a
question for you
but you're free to ask any question you
feel like you should ask
um do you feel
the same way if you left a room of flat
people
or people um non-white people
if they were saying something
behind your back because i well go ahead
i want your answer and then i'll
yeah it's a good question i think it's a
little bit different
now than it was um i never would have
worried about it
um but now
there's a different question which is
you know
did i overcome the expectation that
there's something hidden in my mind
of that nature and it's getting harder
and harder to overcome but
no i never i never would have worried
about that and i think
um you know i i think i deal across
my entire social life you know
race just being one small aspect to this
but i deal
across my life with the sense that if
you
if you approach people openly and you're
candid
about what you see
and you're quick to put things right
when you screw up which we all do
then people get that message pretty
quickly and
you know my sense is that
it used to be generally true that one
could establish that at the very least
i'm trying to live in a world that we
should all
like a good one right i may be wrong
about the details but i'm
shooting for it because i think it's
good for everyone
and i'm not doing so trivially i'm
actually invested in it
and that when people detect that they
they tend to accept your decency
and the the difficulty in establishing
that
now is i think it's
it could hardly be more dangerous
to us so i do i do worry about it more
now
than i did um and i will say
you know i have um
my social universe changed in 2017 when
uh the story at evergreen happened
and i'm in contact with lots and lots of
folks and
you know an especially high number of
black intellectuals and i must say
it is the place that retains this sort
of
sense that this is an arbitrary issue
between us
it's not a central issue even though
it's become much more a focus of our
conversations
because it's happening in the world but
there is sort of a sense
um amongst these folks that
you know we know we're well intended
we've established that and
we can talk about virtually anything and
uh
it seems comfortable but it's like that
general sense
that you could talk about anything with
anybody once you established
that you were decent has been edited
down to a smaller and smaller group of
people
who are capable of you know keeping the
flame for that
style of interaction
[Music]
yes i do think though
that the more i have conversations with
people
where i would assume that they have
they would have a visceral reaction to
everything i
would say that don't i feel like just
the extremes on both sides of the left
and the right
i feel like there it's such a small pool
but because they're the loudest they are
like almost the brand ambassadors for
that side and everyone thinks that they
represent
what um the other side is and i think
when it comes down to it every i think
everyone wants
a decent interaction with everybody and
everyone's wanting to put the weapons
down but they just don't know are you
really going to
drop your weapon though and not pick it
up
and i think that's why we carry around
the weapon
because we have a paranoia are you going
to use it on me
i won't use it on you but i need it just
in case you do
but i think everyone's exhausted i think
everyone
wants i think most people are the more
the most
the more i talk and interact with people
and i say this in the sense of
i'll talk to someone that figuratively
has the weapon like ready to
swing and the more we talk the more
they're just
like they don't want to hold it it's
heavy
that's how i that's my and i can't say
like my
all my in my anecdotal interactions are
like that's just everyone
but when i encounter
people who i would find
teeter being extremists um
on the left or right and i see
how they're only
being this way or holding these weapons
because they assume
the other side wants revenge or they
assume
an overwhelming amount of people on that
side
wants to get them really that there are
people that do
but majority of people
i don't feel like they do that is okay
so you've now
surprised me quite a bit here i think
maybe similarly to
my surprising you with respect to what
gets said
when a black person leaves the room but
my
sense is that we are i feel like i'm
watching
a revolution in which every institution
that i know of is being transformed and
they're adopting
not only beliefs but policy that i know
just can't be made to work right just
simply will not work
it's going to result in all of these
institutions falling apart and failing
to do
what they need to do which uh
in some cases will be very sad and in
other cases will be a catastrophe
but the idea that most of the
people who are part of the movement that
is driving this
might be exhausted and interested
in putting their weapons down i don't
know
i don't know how that deal gets brokered
but wow would it be smart for us to
figure it out because
you know this is going to be a short
ride if this revolution
wins it's going to destroy the stuff
that makes us strong
and then it doesn't matter how the pie
gets divided it's not going to be much
pie
you know yeah and i do want to be clear
i i guess i don't know if i
heard the full question of what you
asked definitely different
between interpersonal relationships or
conversation happening
with me and like institutions and
universities like it's
that's a different story and i feel like
these kids
are just echo chambers of what their
professors are saying and they don't
even know what they believe but
um yes i do think though
even even them there they might just
feel like this is the way i
show that i'm a part of this movement
and that i want
change and but there's been so many
people
who have walked away
from being a liberal because they're
just like one they see that it's
counterproductive and
the whole ideology backfires on itself
and they say it was exhausting to go
into every single room all the time
and having to like detect if this is
racist this
is sexist is this stuff like
they were like and often times i was
actually creating it in my head
and it wasn't there at all um
and then you can look on the other side
uh
and i'll just use this man as an example
dale davis
you know befriending ku klux klanners
not just people that voted for someone
that people might not like
ku klux klaners who say they hate people
who look just like him
where his friendship has um
you know allowed them i guess in a way
to 200 to 300 of them
to leave willingly not that he said
you know if you if we're friends you
can't be in this no he would go there
because he knew what he was doing and he
knew it was kind of like
a strategic move of love on his part
and that's what i mean the weapons like
people don't
at the end of the day those men
when i listened to the podcast and i
actually saw him in person at nyu and i
and he was with the former ku klux
klaner who talked about
how my hate had nothing to do with black
people it had everything to do with the
fact
i hated myself and he said the majority
of people in these movements
ku klux klans are usually boys that
don't have a father figure who's looking
for community
who is looking for a place of love he's
like
it's almost in the same contrast as
maybe
an inner city kid looking for love with
a gang
he said it's just like we're looking for
something
and instead of doing internal work on
ourselves we project it on
something and that's easy to project it
on black people and if
i have to do that to have kinship with
these people i'm going to do that
and so when you hear these stories time
and
time again on other sides for me i've
come to the conclusion
people are are exhausted but they just
don't
trust the other side
and and don't want to be vulnerable
for the other side but who who goes
first is the question
well so interestingly daryl davis is as
an example
if i think back i've heard many many
conversations
about him in many different racial
contexts i've never heard
anyone say anything negative right
everybody likes the story
right and it's a it's a surprising
interesting
wonderful story and you know it does it
does say all kinds of things you know i
i understand the impulse to do what he
did i have that same
impulse i would not have thought it
would work at the level
that he made it work it's it's a
marvelous testament to
his insight into the situation and his
courage to do it
because you know the instinct to do it
is one thing the
actually taking the risk of doing it is
quite another
but in any case i think again you you
know i'm still a little bit surprised by
your sense that uh at least
interpersonally
people are interested in escaping this
dynamic
right i see it accelerating but if
people really wanted it
to uh be stood down
that would be very very healthy um
now as for you know i think you're
pointing to exactly the
obstacle that will prevent it from
happening which is somebody has to go
first and at this moment that's a very
vulnerable thing to do
on either side but
oh there there's got to be a way and you
know i
increasingly think it's probably going
to have to do
with modeling difficult conversations
so that people understand what that
would look like in other words
if we could illustrate the standing down
of the
tension between individuals where the
tension existed
then there's a lot of room for other
people to
to follow suit 100 and that's why
um i do engage in conversations with
people one i
i the first public like
person that i think was kind of you know
well-known benjamin boyce
i i had a conversation with him in
september
after my article came out in tablet
magazine
free black thought and one i had the
conversation because
i think it was needed at that time
and two i knew his base would not ever
search for me
they would not know my name even if
people over here might know me
i might not be in their algorithm ever
and i
i felt like i was not walking to the
lion's den but i didn't
i was talking about black lives matter
and i know how his base feels about it
but i felt like
if i can humanize this in a way
where the weapons are
down in this conversation with benjamin
and we're having an organic conversation
authentic
and they can see into why
someone would do a blm what's the
purpose
what's why would they want to be on this
mission
and just humanize their sentiments
i was like it's worth a shot and i was
shocked by the reception
it was funny because a lot of the
comments
and then people would come on my channel
and and give comments
and these come scratch subscribers and
it wasn't because they agreed with me at
all
i mean they made it very clear i don't
agree with blm
i don't agree with the fact that you
were willing to have this conversation
and that you're willing to listen and
that i actually did gain
some knowledge into something i never
would have considered
that was a win i was like
this is okay this is what i'm going to
continue to do
and i've gotten a lot of comments now
with my channel where
people are speaking up and i'm not going
to say there's hundreds but i've gotten
at least 15 comments from
white black men and women
and other and hispanic and asian people
talking about you know
i have to do this diversity uh training
or this inclusion training
and i would encourage what i told people
is i encourage you to participate
and raise the issues while you're doing
it in good faith
like don't just be like i don't want to
do this but raise it when you're doing
it so they see that you're actually
trying and that you're now questioning
like well
this actually i see a flaw here like can
we discuss it like discuss it when
you're there with them
um because they're not not going to hear
it if you are just
you know but and then there's a lot of
people are like these are the thoughts
i've had
a lot of black people like this is the
thoughts i've had
they're like i agree with the sentiment
of black lives matter black lives matter
but i also have these issues and now
and now i'm voicing them like stuff like
that is enough
for me um and then also
with with white people saying they're
willing to be more open
to to hearing other people's point of
view um and voicing their own point of
view
and feeling like okay now i know how to
actually shape my conversation where
someone's not thinking i'm trying to
attack them like that's enough
and i think that is what more people
need to do
but it's not easy at all
it's being made more difficult because
you mentioned
benjamin i don't know if you know
benjamin's a good friend of mine
um but he is portrayed
as i am actually as being somehow
on the right and sometimes or even
portrayed as far right or
alt-right and there is actually zero to
it
it's just simply not accurate and so the
problem with that is on the one hand yes
it's very annoying to be
dismissed and portrayed this way but the
worst
effect and i think the reason that it
happens is because there is a desire
to keep the very people who need to hear
it from hearing it
so if you are on the left trying to
figure out what to make of
things at the moment then you're very
unlikely to end up
going to listen to a channel that you've
heard is far right
alt-right whatever right so the point is
it that stigma means that the number of
people who saw
your interaction was less than it might
have been
and that means that it can't do as much
good as it needs to do
which you know frankly if you take
people like you or benjamin
and you put them in these conversations
of course it will do good
right these are these are model
individuals who are capable of having a
model conversation
the problems aren't zero but they're
solvable and the
way to solve them is for people who
don't know
you know the details of what's on the
other side of the conversation to
discover it together and for
the audience to come along so you know i
i don't know what percentage of the
problem
has to do with uh people
being driven away from channels that are
the ones they most need to hear but i
think it's significant
[Music]
yeah i i've
i you know read up and watched
you know um the evergreen issue
with you and then uh with
benjamin post a lot about it um before i
did the podcast with him
and i was just dumbfounded at how that
even happened at all like but the thing
is
is i was like but brittany
you would have been one of those people
five years six years ago
actually um which is why i always give a
hum
i'm not saying for you to do this
because it happened to you so i know
keep going i i try to give
not try i give like this
not grace because who am i but like keep
the empathy tie
with people that i once
was aligned with because i know what you
are
feeling and you actually are usually
questioning yourself
because you're human and there will be
times where i would do things to where
it wouldn't align with my moral compass
inside but outwardly i'm i'm putting my
fists up but inwardly i'm like
there's some off and i feel like there's
they're i'm not saying all of them
but there's people over there that know
something's off about this and the more
people have the conversations about why
it's off
the more people are going to start
listening and being like you know what
they're right and i and i have to stop
this but
i would say one thing i did on my
channel
which actually made it which actually
kind of went viral was
i knew that okay so jordan peterson for
instance
i learned about jordan peterson
after the controversy i had no clue who
this man was
didn't know he was a controversial
figure at all
i just came upon a panel he was on
and he specifically just stood out
because i was like wow he's really
challenging um me not necessarily on
race issues just by
critically thinking like that is like
really insightful
how he is thinking about these things
and reframing things i never would have
saw that way and it makes perfect sense
now
so i kept listening to him and listening
and then i stumble across a controversy
that says he's a transphobic
white supremacist i was like i'm like
wait let me see if i put that in google
right because i don't think that's what
they that's not the same man and i'm
like
what what so then i was watching those
videos of people
you know calling him that and chanting
him and shutting
lectures of his down protesting and
i watched the c16 bill all the way
through and him and i was just
like but i would have been those people
too
before i would have went with the mob
and the
fact that i these people are
so off and the fact that i was so off
on things too
i that still dumbfounds me but
long story short i'm a fan of i'm a fan
of him i like him not to say i love
everything like of course i don't get
everything he says but as a thinker i
think like he
is very important and i did a video
about five things i learned
about um jordan peterson on my channel
and all it said was dear jordan peterson
from a former black lives matter pro and
i knew
i okay yes click bait sue me people
people are trying to live in this world
but but i am
and i knew people were like gonna click
on it because they're like this black
lives matter person is gonna
try to grow jordan and i'm gonna but all
they saw
was me just you know coming in with a
funny intro and being
like so i heard about this guy jordan
didn't even bring up the controversy
didn't just as a man that i just
found as if i didn't know anything about
the controversy at all
and just said i learned this thing and
this thing and this thing and now it has
almost 14 000 views
and almost 50 percent of the comments
are
i was coming in here thinking i was
going to defend him and then i left
like sharing this with someone and then
this gives me hope
and this this and and they're like
um we might not align politically but
the fact that
you see who he is
it's just stuff like that i'll do and
and i know that i don't need to say much
the fact that a black woman is talking
about jordan peterson is enough i don't
have to
do his revenge tour like just me
giving that video was me negating the
fact that i don't think
he is someone that hates women and that
is a white supremacist
yeah of course there's people that are
like he's i'm like
go somewhere but stuff like that like
yeah and then yes it it's not easy to do
like everyone's like oh you're so brave
i'm like i don't know if it's bravery
but it's necessary i think
things like that's necessary and
so i do things like that on my channel
and then and then i have another video
about
how tahasi copes with my professor and i
love him people just don't know how to
like wait you like jordan and tom how do
you like them both
like well you can
yeah and maybe you should understand why
i do
i went like oh it's a premise right
so yeah so that's that's marvelous
um i there's so many things i want to
say in response i'll try to try to
remember them but
um one thing is it's pretty clear in
your story
that if you had encountered jordan
peterson if you had encountered his
reputation first and then you might not
have even seen his videos
right if you had you know heard that he
was this
vehement white supremacist you might not
have
given him enough of a chance to discover
that actually you got a lot from
his perspective is that fair um
even even with where i am now if i just
came across it i don't i wouldn't go out
on a campaign against them but i would
just click to another video
right definitely i wouldn't yeah so
that's amazing and
very lucky that you encountered stuff in
the order that you did i'm i'm
quite fond of jordan um
[Music]
but the other thing is what i what i
love most about your perspective is that
it's clear
in many of the stories that you've told
that you start from
the evidence or from your experience of
the world
and you reason from it you're not
working backwards from the conclusion
that this that or the other is true and
so you keep arriving at places
that don't align with these stories that
we're being told
and you have the courage to stick with
what you've figured out rather than
be bullied into accepting what the the
crowd is saying
so that's marvelous and you know i also
hear in your
in your story you said you know i mean
amazing
for you to say to me that had you been
at evergreen you probably would have
been
on the other side um but i'm i'm glad
that you did say it and
i you probably have heard from benjamin
when you spoke to him that you know he
and i both have
maintained from the beginning that most
of the people
who were on the so-called other side
were
good people who were confused about what
was going on
right there were some bad people but it
was not a large number it was a tiny
number and they misled a lot of other
people
and so you know i take a certain amount
of flack for saying that
people they actually don't like it when
um
when i leave that open and i say you
know good people
acting on bad information that that
feels like
i'm giving more credit than is due but i
know it's not the case
right i know that basically there aren't
you know it'd be hard to accumulate that
many bad people
right these had to be people who were
you know i think
too easily persuaded but nonetheless
people recoverable people people who
aren't you know
intent on doing harm yeah um and so it's
uh
it's actually lovely to hear that from
you that you recognizing yourself that
you would have been on the other side
and that you know and that your your
growth has put you somewhere where you
now see
that that would have been an error
that's great yeah
and encountering jordan in that way
because when i went to
nyu the concentration of my
uh journalism degree was in criticism
so i was already on this journey of
going there and thinking i'm gonna be a
cultural critic yeah but i was
being interrogated by my own way of
thinking
all the time and being challenged and
realizing i needed to get a new vetting
system
on how i looked at stuff but with jordan
was such a stark
um it was it was this evidence of you
have to
wait to make logical sense of something
for yourself before you make a
conclusion
you cannot just go based on the majority
because it was such an example of
the majority of people in a sense you
would say
think this of him and it's objectively
not true like it
and it wasn't a conclusion that i said
one with one video
they're wrong no it actually i would say
about a week i i was looking at stuff
and i'm like yeah i've seen enough this
isn't real like
i but i had but i understood like
you said the mob if your friends say
that's the enemy
this person's bad you trust your friends
you trust the people that are on your
side that's aligned with you
and you don't ask questions you pick up
your weapon and they're the enemy
and that is the how it goes for the
majority of the time
i feel um
because
there's times for me so let's just i
don't i don't know i'm sorry if i'm
going off you're fine but um
i'll say i made a conclusion about this
person and now we've had zoom calls and
we're i would say
friends i hope he would call me his
friend but um
my my peace free black thought when i
the reason why i i did that
was one that experience with jordan
peterson and other things and
going through my program um
made me realize that
people have to really the the art of
critical thinking is
is very important and
not to make assumptions of people um
before
hearing out what's actually the evidence
so
coleman hughes when he gave his
speech um at the congressional hearing
against taunting coats this is
when tanahasi was my professor and i
remember being at nyu
and i tuned in and i was rooting for my
professor
and as i was reading for him i saw
coleman i'm like
oh he's he's anti-black he's confused
he's a [ __ ] whatever
but then now
a year ago when i went through all of
this stuff
and really taking myself to task on why
i've come up with conclusions that are
kind of faulty actually
that don't really make sense that i'm
like am i an echo of something or is
this my idea
i went back and i watched that
congressional hearing
and i still thought coats was right in
certain respects but then i listen to
coleman i'm like
and he's for me he's also right they
have different point of views of this
thing and
yeah it's controversial but it's
truthful stings a little but
what he's saying i don't know if it's
all the way wrong and i still agree with
coats and i was just like
wow and i remember writing to coleman
giving him that not knowing what he'd
think because i
in the piece it says i call him a [ __ ]
so i'm like oh i don't know how this is
gonna go over
and he was just like wow this is amazing
and he retweeted it and then
everyone saw it and then him and i have
had conversations
and i think also that's what it comes to
it comes to
when people realizing they're wrong
and are willing to admit that and make
amends with it
and hopefully people that
down the line who um mobbed
you to say the least evergreen hopefully
they
come to they reassess that moment
and maybe realize that they were wrong
and
find a way to make it right but
people just don't want to be wrong yeah
people just want to believe what they're
doing is
right because at the end of the day
people
want to be good and and i think
everyone's confused on
how to be good so they go down well
anti-racism
ali i'm going to be the best anti-racist
i'm gonna call
everyone and or i'm gonna go down this
way or this way this way
people are trying to find a way to be
good and
not to say we someone has the solution
but
obviously right now we're all confused
yes
try to make sense of it that's true i
say uh the most any of us
are is half awake um so every so often
somebody contacts me and they
tell me that they had they were on the
wrong side of the evergreen
situation and i get apologies from them
and i always tell them i don't need an
apology
as long as you are willing to be honest
with yourself
and others that you were on the wrong
side and
you know uh that that's good enough
that's that's what i need from people
and
um you know so anyway that i i hope
maybe some will
uh will hear this and think about that
possibility based on
your courage i mean you obviously
weren't there but uh your courage and
modeling
your you know you don't even have to say
what side you would be on and yet you're
courageous enough
to to say that you would have you would
have called it incorrectly
but i also maybe the last thing we
should talk about since we've we've been
at this for quite some time
is you know you mentioned tonight coates
[Music]
and coleman hughes and jordan peterson
and i must say these are all people that
i get
something really important from i'm a
huge fan of of coleman's there are a
couple places in which he and i
differ but um overwhelmingly i think
he's
uh he's got it right there are
substantial places where i differ
with tonahisi coats but i will say
our family together read between the
world and me
and we got a lot out of it and
i i i think it's very valid i i don't
see him in the same light as i see
ibram kendy you know or robin deangelo
or
other leaders of this movement who i see
as
either so painfully confused that they
are beyond help uh or cynical
you know but no coats is a very
different
very different phenomenon and you know
peterson is
so anyway i guess the point is
interesting
that you and i are coming from very
different perspectives
land on all of these individuals as uh
simultaneously tapped into the truth at
an important level and not saying the
same thing as each other
right so that tells me something this is
a this is a
worthy list and um i would love to see
more interactions that
allowed their differences to
be sorted out yeah
and and with that
i think people think because if one
likes
you know let's just let's just say
thomas soul they can't like tell nazi
coats
or walt whitman you can't like james
baldwin
for me i don't take anyone as a bible
i don't believe in someone
wholeheartedly
um oftentimes i find that
i look at thinkers and writers and
philosophers
not like the solution to it's almost
like arithmetic
like not a solution to it but like a
factor to get to a solution
because there's so many essays that i've
written
where i will bring in you know
i'll bring in thomas soul but thomas
soul said something that might not be
completely let's just say finnish but
james baldwin actually said something
that helps connect and flush this out
but then coleman said this and then
you know tony morrison said that and
jordan peterson actually says something
about
you know cleaning up your room and this
actually helped like i see it all
as like spices on a rack
in the kitchen and that every spice is
for every dish
but sometimes you need to mix it up
and so that's how i see thinkers and
i don't i don't think because you're on
a side or this side i think the whole
side thing is arbitrary and the binary
needs to be squashed
so i don't even think of it like that i
just
read something and if i get something
out of this person and i realize they
have a lot to give
then they go on my shelf and i pull them
off if i need to pull them off
and they might be completely polarizing
in ideas
but the thing is is sometimes they're
looking at the same thing from different
angles
and then i'm adding my angle and that's
actually filling out
and flushing out the issue more and
seeing it through one lens
yep you know i actually i got this from
your
uh your tablet piece about the
debate between booker t washington and
w.e.b du bois
um uh just i must tell you i was
completely unaware at a historical level
about the
two positions and the conflict between
them and
frankly it's funny we're almost having
the very same
discussion to this day about you know
it's sort of a
personal responsibility versus uh
you know active correctives
um and uh and you know
it ain't one or the other there's a
nuanced conversation to be had
about what the right admixture is
um but we're not having that
conversation because of as you point out
the polarization
so anyway i would suggest that uh people
who are interested to check out your
article in in tablet magazine which is
available
online anything you want to say in
closing
let's get along um i like it i mean
yeah i mean i think
that
everyone if if i can give advice of how
i've been able to
um get on this journey
because i'm not done at all
interpersonal work looking at yourself
and figuring out what you believe why
you believe certain things
and seeing what your ideas are made of
and trying to um reassess the conflicts
in your life
are they your conflicts why are they
just simple answers are solutions to
your
own self first
um because if you don't do that all
you're going to do
is the work you need to be doing for
yourself you're going to project that
all on someone else and being like no
they need to fix themselves they need to
do the work and you haven't even touched
what you need to
consider about yourself so
be the change you want to see cliche
well it's it's uh look there's a scale
at which that advice doesn't work but i
think at this scale it works great
and i would uh say based on what we've
talked about i think
we need a
i don't want to over complicate it i
think we need people
to embrace something that i would label
let's try this right where people have
conversations
that are more difficult than they should
be
in order to see how far they can get you
know the conversation you and i are
having
is such a conversation but i think you
and i are probably
both built to make this easier but in
general
what i want to do is have people who
wouldn't ordinarily be sitting down
together
and who might fear what would happen if
they did right
trying it out and maybe you know i i
think your
your idea of setting out
an explicit uh
code of ethics or conduct for your blm
chapter when you started it is exactly
the right one i have advocated this many
times that the way
to prevent institutions from falling
apart is to make
what people within the institution owe
each other absolutely explicit
at the point you walk through the door
and not figure it out after things go
wrong
right so conversations in which
the ground rules are clear right that
you can set a limit for how bad things
can go
right let's let's do this let's have a
conversation and if it goes completely
wrong
it ends here right this conversation is
what it is but it doesn't go farther
than this
and then let's be candid with each other
because i think
and i hope that it was true of this
conversation that maybe each of us
learned something about what we can't
personally know
that was actually positive i know that i
did
and i have the sense based on what you
said of you know your fears about what
gets said in rooms
when you're not there and what i'm
telling you the reality is
that's a that's a big discovery
it is um and that will help
and yeah just
people um willing to have the courage
just to have the conversation what's the
worst that can happen i mean what really
is the worst that can happen
yeah especially on zoom like come on
just shut the laptop if it gets too
heated i mean that's
um but that actually is like what is the
worst that can happen and
don't knock until you try it because
i've had
the best conversations this past year
with people that i
never never would have before
and it could have been a push of
quarantine but it's a push of my
curiosity as a person
but yeah i i would
just say just have the courage to try
just try
so beautiful i think this is this is a
wonderful note
and i'm glad i'm glad that we did this
and
uh i i hope it serves as a model because
um you know it does it creates exactly
that positive sense
uh of you know having
looked a bit through somebody else's
eyes so anyway i i'm grateful for
your willingness to to do this and um
and the grace with which you approach
what has become a very difficult problem
thank you for having me i enjoyed this
conversation awesome
all right well um i think
where can people find you you can find
if you go to american shade
on youtube you'll find all my social
media handles there
so american shade on youtube
yes terrific all right um
brittany king it's been marvelous and uh
to everyone who tuned in thank you for
doing so and we'll see you next time
on dark horse be well everyone thank you